salut à tous ces pêcheurs de 13 ans
alors aujourd'hui je suis à villeneuve
les béziers
un spot que j'ai jamais fait je suis
jamais plus dans cette ville d'ailleurs
il le dernier jour avant le confinement
donc j'espère trouver du lourd pour
pouvoir partir continue en paix et voilà
j'ai un collègue qui va me rejoindre
donc c'est parti pour la pêche
[Musique]
allez
moi je m'en soucier
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est cool il ya des trucs
alors
peut-il heures
[Musique]
voix
aller là bas
ah je pensais pas qu'ils restent
longtemps tu vois
une bonne partie
bougies de voiture
déjà non
à voter arrête
[Musique]
mais en publiant for your way you lie
j'ai rempli
abouti à la belge
en fait ce côté prochaine fois ça va pas
l'autre
oui déjà un moment non mais ouais les
mecs sont pas fils d'en devenir à la clé
double face à l'acte
[Musique]
voilà non c'est sur ce que sont venus à
ya plein de crue le sens là
[Applaudissements]
regarde n'importe quoi j
[Musique]
dubois love and play one team elle est
morte
sortez la clé marx est là pour le coup à
la haye les filles à ses vieux fers à
repasser sa way
c'est la peinture
on avait tort
non
avant d'écrire porte-clés abattage et
laqué de la clio moi j'ai le porte-clés
aller là on a quelque chose encore les
gt and clean vehicle est aussi une pièce
parce qu'elle sait peut-être pas du
franc et la couleur sylvie françois a
peut-être saint denis france ge et
safran 50 jours au port j'aime me fait
l'amour à la polonaise
pas mal ah oui à colombier c'est
vraiment le foot avant de tout quoi
aller et du coup il ya du vert et tout
[Musique]
bonjour merci on nettoie au ça arrive à
des outils qui sont tombés des péniches
ouais
à béziers beziers nickel
[Musique]
c'est dur à y croire mais des freins et
des scooters des vélos 1
[Musique]
merci
encore un franc 2 me fera encore
auger trouvait même encore plus de 2000
francs à lens est allé arracher comment
commence à peu lâché 1 barbarian a pas
mal
champion des changes
c'est allé voir qu'elles font tuer
j'aime y passons un chargeur et ses
paroles ans à l'époque
on ya cinquante un truc tout faire nous
dire
[Musique]
non
rivel ouais c'est pour les élus ça on
sait manuel
[Musique]
c'est notre fils à toulouse
et franchement
[Musique]
alé lô revolver palais qui revient quand
même sous seront par contre son état dur
de faire un film sur twitter pire face à
la révolte arabe roche obtient j'ai
revolver mois au regard était il ya le
nom de la personne ne croit elles sont
pas les noms
c'est toujours à 100 ouais
[Musique]
j'ai pas trouvé la personne ou la pop au
port c'est très bon ça c'est pas une
dizaine de kilos
ouais d'accord c'est plus dur en fait
et je me suis dit c'est peut-être encore
revolver mais non
[Musique]
oh pas mal fait fondre couteau à beurre
ah ouais ouais non
la banque entend
il entendu
[Musique]
d'avoir trop douter
ok
il est étrange
je m'excuse auprès du policier de
l'erreur collé la photo de darmanin mais
l'occasion était trop belle l'équipe a
été très professionnelle et tolérante
envers notre ignorance
j'ai pu profiter de leur présence pour
remettre la clé de voiture que je venais
de trouver
nous avons fait l'erreur de ne pas nous
renseigner au préalable de la présence
d' arrêté interdisant la pêche élément
ne fait pas la même erreur et renseignez
vous voici la raison de l'interdiction
de la pêche allemand dans cette ville
quand les halles mal sont partis à
débâcle dix ans ils se soldent l'est et
toutes les munitions et les objets jetés
juste en face dans le dans le canal le
risque c'était que quelques enfants et
pris l'habitude de venir empêcher avec
des mines et mende et est montée ces
mines est donc évidemment c'est pas le
fait deux péchés qui est dangereux mais
après la mène la manipulation de ces de
ces engins peut être dangereux et dont
il était nécessaire d engrais plus de
200 kg d'explosifs ont été retirés du
canal du midi à villeneuve les béziers
donc pour les trouvailles en a deux
pièces de 2000 francs 2 74 et 72 un
leurre et un lors de folie avec 5
hameçons pour un tout petit l'heure il
est pas mal un bouchon de pêche encore
et surtout le revolver à broche
donc vous voyez ce qui brille là ça veut
dire qu'il est chargé ce à dire qu'il ya
des cartouches à broche à l'intérieur
pour celui là il est vraiment dans un
sale état
le canon ce qui est impressionnant c'est
que le canon est encore ouvert mais
autrement il est bien abîmée mais c'est
une belle trouvaille je suis content
pour ceux que ça intéresse nous avons
sélectionné quelques reportages youtube
sur la récupération des explosifs datant
de la guerre en commentaire de cette
vidéo on tenait aussi à remercier tous
nos abonnés pour votre soutien et vos
super commentaires que l'on adore lire
et à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures